They called me, I think, like 2 o'clock in the afternoon.
By 7 o'clock that evening, Carmela and her four children
were moving into the Church of the Advocate.
It was an act of resistance against the tone in this country
and the practice that was going on within the administration
to attempt to continue to marginalize and criminalize people
who are coming to this country for asylum.
Who are coming here for safety and security.
I have to resist it in any way that I can.
And that's also part of my faith.
I believe that social justice work
is part of the DNA of the Church of the Advocate.
In 1968, we hosted a meeting of the Black Power conference [with] over 5,000 people.
In 1970, it was a Constitutional convention of the Black Panther's party,
happened right here in this sanctuary.
And then in 1974,
we hosted the ordination of the first eleven women to the episcopal priesthood.
We knew that we were also, to some extent, chartering new ground
in terms of having an African-American congregation welcoming someone from Mexico,
who was not a native English speaker, does not speak English at all.
What we are doing is not harboring Carmela and her family.
We've made it real clear from the moment that she stepped foot on the premises,
that ICE officials, everybody who need to know that Carmela's here,
that has been public knowledge.
So harboring for me suggests that
we've been trying to conceal this.
And we haven't.
If the officials want to come in and take possession of Carmela and her children,
as long as they have the proper paperwork,
they certainly have their right to do that.